l'antenne ffv de trappes c'est avec
celle de rouen l'un des deux centres
d'essai français de l'entreprise f v
autrefois testeurs de moteur thermique
elle s'est convertie récemment vers
l'électrique en 2011 on a eu un premier
centre d'essai batterie mais limiter en
taille
typiquement pour aider renault a
développé la zoé et puis ça s'est
accéléré il ya trois ans en 2018 on a eu
des demandes de partout et puis on a on
est passé d'une activité thermique pur
et un peu de batterie à une activité
100% électrique à saint quentin en
yvelines aujourd'hui les techniciens et
ingénieurs travaillent essentiellement
sur les batteries et moteurs de leurs
partenaires avant la production et des
tests très rapide en général de ce qu'on
appelle les tests de performance on
vient tester les performances ou d'une
batterie soit d'un moteur électrique et
puis à des tests beaucoup plus longs des
tests d'endurance sur du moteur
électrique c'est facile l'endurance d'un
moteur électrique c'est du
vieillissement et un éclairement moteurs
électriques posés à l'arrêt en attente
il élude ne vieillit pas de plus en plus
la question se pose du futur de
l'électrique pour alfred arpin il est
compliqué d'évaluer avec précision sa
part dans l'industrie automobile de
l'avenir il ya à la fois d'un côté les
décisions politiques qui font qu'on va
dans un sens c'est y aller le rationnel
technique qui fait qu'on peut aller dans
un autre sens il faut qu'on arrive
aujourd'hui bien échanger entre nous
tous pour converger pour étudier les
technologies embarquées fb possède
également attrape un service mobilité
intelligente entre connectivité
assistance conduite systèmes de recharge
ils travaillent sur ces nouvelles
technologies l'idée est d'aller de plus
en plus loin dans ses
différentes fonctions le problème étant
bien sûr le coup embarqué de tous ces
systèmes qui nécessitent d'être validée
d'être sûre elle faisait étudier aussi
la question de l'adaptabilité du
véhicule il sera probablement question
dans le futur d'acheter une voiture dont
le moteur est adaptée selon son usage
quotidien ou ponctuelles pour des
courtes ou longues distances